Chúng tâm dự bó ký tượng thủy văn cua xa trở biết từ ngày 20 tư, tình trạng nắng tạnh như cua vực trên cả nước có su hơn 30 dần.
Giang cua vực Trung bộ hả năng dự nhiệt só hơn từ ngày 20 tư.
Trong các ngày 4 vàng nắng thương nắng nắng cây khác và đặc biệt kê khác tiếp tục diễn xa trên sử dọc.
Cua vực tế bác bộ phục biến từ bám lâm đến bám biệt bà biệt dụ xe, con nơi trên bám biệt dụ.
Đồng bộ xuất hiện nắng nắng cộ bộ có nguyên nhé độ vượt bám lâm độ.
Đáng chú ý, cua vực tức tăng ngoài đến thành phố ấy khi nhận nắng ngay khác, con nơi đặc biệt li khát,
với nhé độ phổ biến từ bám biệt tâm từ 1 mi đổ.
Con nơi trên 1 mi đổ.
Tại nắng và phía đông có tình từ khoảng ngày đến đặc lắc,
nhé độ các nhé phổ biến từ bám biệt sau đến bám biệt tảng lượng xe,
cua vực công hình Trung bộ và năng bộ dưới chỉ mức bám lâm đến bám biệt sau đổ.
Cơ quan khi tượng cảnh báo, nắng nắng kéo sài ký thở biệt độ ẩm thấp,
lâm ra thông hình cơ trảy nổ tại khu dân tư, giòn như cầu sử dụng liển tăng cao, đông thời anh hửa lịch sức khoảng lý dân.
Các chuyên gia quyền cáo hạn chế xanh ngoài cho khu dơ nắng khác, bầu sử lụng nguyên xuất dụng chanh phục bảo hộ và chính là bị quá sức trong môi trường như độ cao.